I'm Ed Curry and I grow the hottest
peppers in the world let's answer some
questions from the internet this is
pepper
[Music]
support at Dustin diki asks Peppers why
do you hurt me Peppers don't actually
hurt you it's the capsacin that's in the
pepper that is reacting with a trvp1
receptor that only mammals have to send
a signal to your brain that we perceive
as heat it's just a brain trick to tell
you not to eat the fruit there is no
actual heat it will not hurt you at box
Vergo asks did you know Birds can't
taste capsacin yes I did know that only
mammals can taste capsacin they're the
only ones with the trvp1 receptor that
sends the signal to the brain at the
Jake de asks what kind of peppers do
they use to make pepper spray the
military uses jalapenos because they're
so damn cheap but they use a lot of them
to extract the capsacin there is a
company that makes bear spray that uses
Carolina Reaper it costs a lot more and
it's a lot more potent on the end
product at atha asks quick question why
does drinking milk help with spicy food
I hate to tell you but drinking milk
does not help with spicy food what
they're doing is coating all the
membrane inside your mouth therefore
shutting off the reaction with the trvp1
receptor but saliva eats through
carbohydrates really fast all a sudden
you're hot again and you drink more milk
so you wind up drinking a half gallon of
milk and then you throw up all over the
place and then you say oh that Pepper
made me throw up no it didn't it was the
half gallon of milk you drank don't
drink milk drink citric acid it's just a
matter of time before it's going to go
away at tus B asks how can I reduce the
heat of the peppers in my hands I have
washed it tce with deter so what causes
the heat on your hands is the oil that
the capin in it's called oo resin and
that gets into all the grooves in your
hand if you use hot water what you're
doing is opening up all the pores in
your skin and letting that oil go in
which is just going to make it last a
whole lot longer start with cold water
citric acid like lemon juice or lime
juice will also cut that oil makes it go
away a lot faster at pcore nettling ass
I have have no idea what the health
benefits for various raw hot peppers but
I've been eating them near daily for a
month now and I feel great that's
awesome I eat peppers on a daily basis
too and I always feel great health
benefits one because of the heat that we
perceive the body releases dopamine and
endorphin into your system that calms
your nerves and makes you feel good and
gives you kind of euphoric feeling like
a runner's high peppers are really
really high in vitamin C and vitamin A
they raise your metabolism they help
with digestion people think Peppers will
give you an ulcer no they kill the
bacteria that gives you ulcer at Megan
Murray asks why are pepper seeds so much
hotter than Peppers # nonsense well at
Megan Murphy that is #n what it is
that's hot is the membrane that the
seeds are attached to this white
membrane in here that the seeds are
attached to that is what is producing
the Heat if you took the seeds and
washed them in hydrogen peroxide and
then ate one there'd be no heat at all
because you've taken the oil off that
seed you just got to watch out for this
membrane that's inside now in a super
hot pepper that membrane goes all the
way around the fruit but in something
like a jalapeno it's in very defined
ribs the skin on a jalapeno only has
about a third of the Scoville uh that
the membrane has at Joe 6884 649 90
anyone tell me what is the hottest
pepper in the world well the hottest
pepper in the world used to be smoking
EDS Carolina Reaper at 1.64 2 million
Scoville heat units this is pepper X
which is now the new Guinness World
Record for the hottest pepper in the
world at
2693 million Scoville heat units over a
million hotter than the Carolina Reaper
which was my record for 10 years at Jill
Rosenthal ask what is a Scoville well a
Scoville might refer to wilver Scoville
who is the invent of the scale known as
the Scoville heat units a high
performance liquid chromatograph was
invented and that measures all the
compounds in a whole bunch of different
things including Peppers this bell
pepper has absolutely no skillville heat
units jalapeno which is about 3,000
Scoville heat units a Hungarian hot
pepper which can go up to about 10,000
Scoville heat units Fresno maybe 20,000
habenero this about 100,000 Scoville
heat units the chocolate botlo which is
about 1.4 million Scoville heat units
Carolina Reaper 1. 642 million Scoville
heat units and a gnarly pepper x
2.69 3 million Scoville heat units at
Alex Zealand asks tonight's dinner
conversation
how exactly do you breed hotter and
hotter Peppers well Alex you need to
have two pepper plants and those two
plants have to have the right compounds
in them that you're looking for these
aren't pepper plants but this is the way
that you crossbreed any of the plants
you want to try crossbreeding you take a
fine paintbrush and you go to the first
flower and you roll that paintbrush
around in the flower and then you go to
a flower on a different plant and try to
transfer the pollen as the bud turns
into a pepper and the fruit starts
growing hey is this the fruit that I
really want does it taste like I want
you take the seeds out and you replant
that if that grows the same exact fruit
then you've got the first generation of
your cross breed the time span between
crossing a pepper and achieving
stability is 8 to 12 generations for us
we can do that in 6 Years cuz we have
green houses but if you're doing it at
home it's going to take you 10 years at
least uh to get a stable plant at Stone
shed crafts ass can I save seeds from
inside Peppers dry them and use them to
grow pepper plants in the spring how
about chilies too pepper plants and
chili plants are all the same family
okay so you can do that I do that that's
how I get all of my seeds we take each
and every seed out of a pepper plant and
then you know I save from every single
pepper a few seeds for the future I have
about
7800 different kinds of peppers that
I've saved seeds from it's a long
process when you're doing it I recommend
wearing gloves but you can just pull the
ribs out let them dry separate the
pepper seeds I wash them in a little bit
of hydrogen peroxide and water and it
takes the heat off at AKA Cinders ass I
have the hardest time with peppers I
can't seem to get them to grow no matter
what I do I haven't hit the right
conditions yet what happens most of the
time when people fail with pepper plants
is they're trying too hard peppers are a
weed if you have Sun you have dirt and
you have water you have the right
conditions and the plant will tell you
when it needs water anytime you see that
plant start to wilt give it a little
more moisture it'll stand right back up
again now the first mistake most people
make is they plant the seed too deep
birds eat the seeds they transport them
they poop them out and then a pepper
grows they're taking a poop and flying
away that's how deep you need to put
that pepper seed an eighth of an inch at
W6 oy asks how does the Scoville scale
measure the exact hotness of peppers
it's a chemical process first what we do
is dehydrate peppers for approximately
96 hours then we emulsify them and boil
them a small sample is taken out and put
into a machine called high performance
liquid chromatograph is commonly
referred to as the hplc and that machine
gives us a graft and that graft has
Peaks where all the different compounds
are and we know these Peaks are capsacin
dihydro capsacin and nordal hydroc
capsacin the area of those Peaks is then
put into a chemical equation from the
American Association of analytical
chemists and that gives you the exact
Scoville heat units of that pepper
sample at Charlie marks as when are
pepper breeders going to stop when is
too many scoville units too many right
now we have Peppers that are 2.6 million
or higher theoretically if the models
are correct we can get that up to about
7.9 million but it's going to take a lot
of time at DOI yanga ask yeah so how do
you make hot sauce first
ingredient has got to be Peppers either
in a pepper Mash form or fresh Peppers
you take fresh Peppers that have been
dest stemmed with a little bit of
vinegar you only need somewhere between
8 and 14% of the volume in vinegar and
then you heat that up and you get it to
a boil and then you can it and that is
fresh pepper mesh and then you need a
little bit of vinegar to acidify it a
little bit more we're going to
guesstimate
about one cup next ingredient people
like salt it's about a teaspoon that's
all you need I'm going to put in a
little bit of onion powder and a little
bit of garlic powder garlic gives a
little bit of body in there and all that
goodness and flavor black pepper is a
spice it is not a pepper and what I like
to do if you have it at home you take a
little bit of turmeric is it livens up
the taste first you have to mix it up
and then you put it on the stove and you
heat it up to a minimum of
185° after that is done you can put it
in a container and put it in the
refrigerator hot sauce by law right now
has a 2-year shelf life but science that
has to do with that pH says it's good
for 8 to 10 years no issues at all at
keson asks everyone what is your
strategy on how to win a hot pepper
eating contest starting to think I might
be in over my head you're going to need
to do hotter and hotter Peppers start
with jalapenos then maybe go to Fresnos
if you're daring you might just up to a
habanero and you eat those then you look
for a ghost pepper and you eat those so
the next question comes from Andy doodle
56 I just been into a Carolina Reaper it
hurts so good but WTF what's happening
to my body so Andy I think the best way
to explain what is happening to your
body is to bring in a victim Bella is
going to eat this Reaper so the first
thing that happens when she bites into
the pepper you get the sweet taste but
then the heat hits and immediately from
the back of your throat all the way
through your mouth there's an explosion
just like lava those trvp1 receptors are
shooting signals to your brain and
you're going to have a fight response or
you're going to have a flight response
now when you have the fight response you
kind of look like she does her body is
starting to sweat it's getting into her
blood system so she might or might not
feel a little like her arms feeling a
little bit lighter or different parts of
her body tingling what your body starts
doing is pumping dopamine and endorphin
into your system kind of akin to a
narcotic and it's going to give you a
runers high when you are hot your body
starts sweating it's trying to cool you
down how do you feel like I feel floaty
my throat and my tongue absolutely feel
searing pain um I'm having a hard time
concentrating like I heard maybe five
words you
said and it feels like my throat is
wanting to close and it's on fire it
almost feels uh very puffy right here
and that's a precursor to Capas and
cramps if you're feeling that way just
get on out of here Heather all right you
got it I wouldn't recommend anybody
doing a whole pepper the best way to do
it is to cut it into little slices and
just taste it at I exude sarcasm ass
when people eat that is made with
raw ghost peppers and all those spicier
peppers do they lose a bit of the lining
in their colon if it doesn't cause
ulcers or anything like that but what
does happen is that massive amount of
capace and your body is perceiving as a
poison your stomach exrs it into the
smooth muscle and you get a cramp and
that cramp can be very very painful and
they come in waves guys think they're
dying but they're not dying they're just
having a menstrual cramp and they don't
know what it feels like and as the
pepper makes its way through your
intestinal tract it's going to catch up
with your in in Uranus so you might
experience The Burning Ring of Fire at
baby Wasteland asks has anyone ever died
from eating an extremely hot pepper to
my knowledge and through all the
research we've done there has been no
record of anybody dying from eating an
extremely hot pepper the only real
concern you need to have do you have an
allergy to night shades CU peppers are
in the nightshade family most people
know that because they've been given
Tomatoes when they were young do do you
have a pre-existing heart condition that
can't handle the elevation in metabolism
and do you have an aneurysm anywhere
that's been diagnosed other than that
there's really nothing to fear from
Peppers at Nixie and Saint ask you ever
think about how different Wasabi hotness
is to hot pepper hotness most Americans
have not had Wasabi what they've had is
horseradish that's been dyed horseradish
does not have ksin in it the burn is
from a different compound that we also
perceive as heat we do a Wasabi mustard
with Reaper Peppers that is amazing the
lingering burn from the horseradish
family that happens on the side of your
mouth and in your nasal combined with
the burn from super hot peppers that
goes brutally down your tongue and into
your throat gives me an endorphin rush
like nothing else at Austin till ask
guys what do you think the next hottest
pepper is going to be yeah I think the
next hottest pepper is going to be
pepper why because I developed it I know
the genealogy I know the stability and I
know the testing I have not heard of
anybody out in the pepper Community who
actually has a stable pepper that can
even beat pepper X so when I'm ready to
release pepper y that will be released
thank you for all the questions today
folks it's been an honor to be here
thanks for watching pepper
[Music]
support